there's a small glimmer of hope for
americans struggling with rising prices
the rates of increa the rate of increase
in inflation slowed very slightly last
month though the annual figure was still
close to 40-year highs the consumer
price index increased 8.3 percent from
april 2021 food and gas prices are
seeing some of the biggest hikes the
national average for regular gas hit
another record high this morning at
almost 4.42 a gallon carter evans has
more
when i go into the
grocery store it's sticker shock
jackie say and dennis stevenson are
cutting back i used to try to buy one
month's worth of groceries but not
anymore the retired maryland couple
recently turned to food banks it's not
like it used to be in april prices for
food at home were up more than 10
percent from a year ago with bacon up
almost 18 percent and eggs 22 percent in
addition to rising gasoline and energy
prices the latest numbers show the cost
of shelter and housing was up more than
five percent which may be a low estimate
according to bankrate.com chief
financial analyst greg mcbride the
reality of it is any tenant that has
renewed a release in recent months
they've likely seen a much bigger than
five percent increase in rent how long
are we going to be seeing price
increases like this i think we're easily
in this for another 12 months january
1st we raise prices how much close to 10
percent
bobby java harry doesn't see prices
coming down anytime soon you think
there's more liz back there his company
yeti houseware appliances makes kitchen
supplies in china where coveted
lockdowns are slowing production and
rising oil prices are increasing costs
you need oil to make plastic which also
makes air fryers the cost of air fryers
have gone up five percent because of
volatility and oil prices how does the
wheat crop look
looks pretty healthy to me on wednesday
president biden blamed the war in
ukraine for grain shortages ukraine was
the world's largest producer of wheat
and corn
inflation is now driven by a number of
global events and mcbride says the u.s
government can only do so much to stop
it the federal reserve raising interest
rates to slow the economy that will
address the demand side but it won't fix
the supply chain it won't broker peace
in eastern europe and it won't open the
ports in china for cbs mornings i'm
carter evans in los angeles